[Musique]
depuis 1998 régis belleville découvre le
métier de chameliers auprès des nomades
du sahara là bas on l'a surnommé le
chamelier blanc il a appris la
navigation dans le désert comme d'autres
apprennent l'océan où la montagne dont
le sahara
il est heureux mais il souffre aussi en
2002 il a réalisé une méharée historique
sans aucun point d'eau 49 jours pour
rallier à pied les cités mythiques de
chinguetti et tombouctou
depuis le désert ne quitte plus ses
pensées cette fois régis belleville
décide de traverser le sahara dans sa
plus grande longueur de l'océan
atlantique à la mer rouge avec la
compagnie de ses seuls chameau en
suivant le 20e parallèle d'ouest en est
l'idée semble insensé mais régis durant
des mois s'est préparé au grand départ
[Musique]
derniers préparatifs à nouakchott en
mauritanie lorsqu'il se lance dans cette
traversée solitaire où le combat contre
la soif les privations et la solitude
seront son quotidien
marine lefèvre l'accompagnent dans ses
premiers jours de marche pour la suite
de son périple il se filme e ra avec une
petite caméra et marine avec une équipe
le rejoindra pour de courtes périodes
afin de raconter son aventure
obama
[Musique]
le sahara le plus vaste désert chaud du
monde sépare le continent africain en
deux d'une superficie de plus de 8
millions de kilomètres carrés il s'étend
d'ouest en est sur une distance de 6000
km régis décide de le traverser dans sa
plus grande longueur en suivant une
ligne droite dans sa partie la plus
aride le 20e parallèle 19 59 59 8 en
écriture 20e parlait le quasiment à 3
est prêt
d'un côté à l'autre c'est l'océan il
nous ment site l autre côté c'est désert
là ça y est c'est parti
j'aimerais 6000 kilomètres à faire
la survie va dépendre uniquement des
efforts quotidiens
pour la mériter si tout va bien
maintenant deux prochaines horizon bleu
ça sera la mer rouge dans 6000 km régis
par de la côte atlantique en mauritanie
pour arriver à la mer rouge au niveau du
soudan plus la ligne sera droite plus
vite
il arrivera il sait qu'il lui faudra
sortir le plus rapidement possible de ce
qui risque d'être un enfer en
choisissant ce 20e parallèle il passe
loin de tous les puits de tous les
villages sans jamais emprunté une piste
caravanières il est donc obligé de
prévoir une autonomie de 850 kilomètres
en eau et en nourriture
il lui faut absolument terminer avant
avril après il fera trop chaud pour
continuer je vous présente mon premier
copain que ça ira on s'entendra bien on
va effectuer les 303 180 premiers
kilomètres ensemble ou d'un drôle de
tête comme organe
[Musique]
c'est peut-être aussi
dromadaire bien s'entendre
pourquoi le désert non parce que c'est
un lieu que je connais bien
[Musique]
il ya des gros enjeu de survie par
rapport à l'eau par rapport à la chaleur
ne dépendant complètement nos charmants
cela ne peut pas traverser le désert
celle du minéral j'adore le minéral j'ai
besoin de me trouver face à
l'élémentaire face à avancer pour pas
mourir à me nourrir à dormir est
toujours toujours avancer toujours
[Musique]
juste en face de moi juste en face de
mes capacités mais possibilités des
faiblesses de mes forces
[Musique]
pour l'instant j'ai eu tellement chaud
je dois
4 à peu près à massy league s'inclinant
par jour plus peut-être aventure
sequana rythme qu'il faudra par la suite
il fait trois choses quant à 42,43 de
neige
l'ani savoureux n'est pas donc je perds
beaucoup donc point de conspiration
comme maintenant en plus ça fait qu'une
quatre cinq jours que je marche
donc il faut que le corps s'habitue il
faudra à peu près que la journée pour
descendre à une fois de quatre lettres
géantes etc 100 litres d'eau même forage
le prochain forage dans deux jours mais
il doit me rester peut-être 15 min au 15
et 3 jours pour pâques et d'imprévus
alors lâché au départ
et donc je déplie jamais la carte
mentiez pas prendre peur dans l'eau ce
qui reste encore à faire
c'est mieux comme ça pour le moral
régis voulait atteindre un autre forage
un peu plus loin mais ses chameaux sont
assoiffés avec leurs efforts quotidiens
et l'extrême chaleur ils ont besoin de
boire plus régulièrement
il a fallu qu'ils dévient sa route il
s'est écarté du 20e parallèle mais a
rempli à nouveau ses bidons d'eau le
jour ils avancent en se repérant sur
l'alignement des dunes toute l'année il
y un vent dominant qui vient du nord-est
régis marche avec un angle d'environ
cinq degrés par rapport à cette taxe
[Musique]
j'aime bien découvrir la surprise de la
position gps et là je m'aperçois que
j'ai pas bien avancer vraiment droit 15
donc en fait on se situe un peu près ici
on a une des raisons pour lesquelles je
suis dans le désert pour ça pour ça
parce que les sites néolithiques
m'intéresse c'est cette magie du désert
cette magie du livre ouvert sans
sédimentation qui permet de trouver
comme ça en surface les objets quand des
milliers d'années ici on peut le servir
x et dépose le sable n'a fait que passer
avec le vent donc ça permet d'avoir des
substrats fins des couches des couches
très ancienne qui affleure comme ça
[Musique]
c'est des zones
quand on était très peu explorée très
peu traversée par les hommes et
énormément d'observation à faire donc du
débroussaillage scientifique prendre des
relevés prendre des notes faire des
observations faire quelques prélèvements
de sable pour un labo à toulouse qui
travaille sur les actes inadmissibles et
de bactéries extrêmement fils l avantage
de ces bactéries sais que ça peut
produit en fait les nouvelles molécules
qui seront utilisés dans les médicaments
saïdou persuadé que c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle marche ou d'aller au bout
de moi-même pour ramener quelques
échantillons quelques grammes de sable
ça motive le désert c'est ça il faut se
pencher pour le regarder s'approchait
des choses pour les observer on ne peut
pas observer le désert de loin il faut
s'immerger complètement s'immerger et
c'est vrai que la solitude c'est ce sera
un combat là ça fait quelques jours
c'est important mais je pense que dans
deux ou trois mois ce sera important
sera important je vais elle va prendre
beaucoup de place et je ris de lutte et
de lutter énormément contre la solitude
la soif plus la solitude ça risque de
faire un mélange assez pourquoi
[Musique]
dans le désert on peut approcher la
folie lorsqu'on atteint un seuil
critique de déshydratation un phénomène
de confusion mentale se produit les sens
sont troublés l'ouïe l'odorat la vue
on ne se rend plus compte du temps qui
défile et l'on perd alors la notion
essentielle de vie de survie régis a un
truc
lorsqu'il n'est pas sûr d'être vraiment
en forme il se sert de la trotteuse de
sa montre elle reste un repère pour
savoir s'il conserve la notion du temps
qui s'écoule
ils essayent de compter une minute dans
sa tête et vérifient que l'aiguillât
bien fait une rotation complète s'il
arrive encore à se concentrer pendant
une minute
c'est que tout va bien
[Musique]
comme ce soir là bas j'ai pas de sens
toute façon c'était pas mal en fait une
caméra ce qu'il miroir
[Musique]
je suis malade depuis longtemps la santé
j'ai d'écrire mon vaisseau voilà vous
n'avez sac photo vidéo vers le sac à
bagages c'est le sac technique est de
l'autre côté c'est la bouffe voilà avec
un charmant on peut être autonome et
deux autres pour la flotte
j'ai hâte de trouver un coin mais avec
des acacias pour les chameaux j'ai
encore bouffer mon plat de riz avec la
grèce le peuvent ils appellent ça le
beurre citoyen et lui j'aime bouger et
demain sera un autre jour
tandja dgo
[Musique]
tania la libye
il lui a fallu deux mois et une semaine
pour arriver à tombouctou
après 1800 km de solitude il retrouve
une ville qu'il faut voilà mais avec
avec le cuir tout remplacer l'expliqué
qu'il faut juste remettre
il va profiter de cette escale pour
réparer ou changer le matériel
il doit remplacer sa selle mauritanienne
par une selle touareg
ils cherchent à se fondre dans le
paysage
en épousant les coutumes locales
ça fait deux jours que régis se repose à
tombouctou et cette inaction commence à
lui peser
il est impatient de repartir
[Musique]
chacun a son comportement vestimentaire
bien sûr mais quand tu arrives en ville
avec avec des habits comme on a cinq
textes et la russe mais tous sans
surtout pied pourquoi certains sites
apple beau ici c'est que tu es pauvre tu
peux mais les fermer un peu plus
courtois
juste un petit peu plus loin et donc toi
sont les sons des dessins tous les
dessins d'accord je vais m'intéresser
bien exactement la longueur qui font
[Musique]
tout à l'heure je prends acte et tout à
l'heure quand on traverse le sahara on
peut passer d'un pays à un autre sans
voir de frontières sans rencontrer un
poste de police wind one mais
l'inconvénient de venir en ville c'est
qu'ici tout se sait tout se raconte
[Applaudissements]
régis a eu la visite des renseignements
généraux et de la gendarmerie
témoin d'un trafic illégal au nord de
tombouctou
il est menacé de représailles pour
assurer sa sécurité les gendarmes lui
demandent de suivre la route jusqu'à le
gao
un sacré crochet par le sud dès qu'il le
pourra il remontera sur le 20e parallèle
loin des plus loin des hommes là je veux
en fuite de cette ville
[Musique]
j'ai vu qu'il avait peur il a peur de
tout le monde mais il est très laid très
peur sûrement très très grave que ce
n'est pas tellement de laisser pour
l'essai mais c'est juste pour le bruit
et les bars des scènes ne pas faire
descendre son piège de 17h est pour
l'instant c'est toujours un moment un
peu délicat
un départ parce que basko faut toujours
penser penser à tout évidemment c'est
dans le désert et aura une boutique pour
acheter un morceau de corde odeur ou un
morceau de cuir ou un paquet de nouilles
je pensé à tout mais tout est là je pars
pour une autonomie de d'environ environ
35 jours trente cinq jours jusqu'à la
frontière
ce que la frontière nigérienne
il ya de la rage
ok merci je suis d'accord pas le
problème vient à être rendre visite
si je reviens à tomber je regarde
l'ombre des dromadaires et on regarde
dans l'ombre en fait j'ai pas à me
retourner complètement ni à les voir
tous ça me permet de voir si les bagages
sont toujours bien en place
si j'ai pas perdu un chameau mais là
c'est vrai que je me tourne toutes les
trois minutes presque ça fait quoi ça
fait un kilomètre qu'on commence à faire
connaissance
il faut qu'ils s'habituent à moi qu'ils
aient confiance surtout moi que j'ai
confiance en eux
est ce un moment aussi excitant que
parce que c'est trois nouveaux
compagnons de route et ne savent pas ce
qui les attend
moi non plus mais je sais que je vais
essayer de les garder plus longtemps
possible et laisse se débrouiller pour
se nourrir je ne ramène pas si tu veux
un plateau repas chaque fois donc il se
débrouille il veut se nourrissent et ça
évite qu'ils s'éloignent où
théoriquement qui se met à courir parce
qu'il est clair qu'ils vont souffrir
quand je vais pas leur donner à boire
comme ils ont eu l'habitude d'avoir à
voir souffrir de la soif comme moi
d'ailleurs regarde son palais au comme
ça toi et mange tranquillement sous son
nervosité en voulant faire cette
traversée j'étais persuadé d'être dans
une solitude totale et d'avoir lutté
contre cette solitude et j'ai pas arrêté
de rencontrer du monde
j'ai rencontré beaucoup plus de monde
que j'avais j'avais envisagé c'est
encore pas réellement senti seul
vraiment seul en fait c'est une région
le problème c'est que les autorités sur
le 20e parallèle dans aucun pouvoir
c'est un secteur uniquement contrôlé par
la contrebande
ceux qui font la loi donc le trafic se
fait surtout nord nord sud moi je
traverse toutes ces pistes de
trafiquants en ayant pris la direction
est ouest est
il fallait que je m'arme donc je partis
avec un pistolet 9 mm acheter au front
polisario évidemment une arme de
contrebande mais j'avais l'impression
que ça allait me rassurer trois fois
j'ai été sur le point de m'en servir
et je pense que je l'aurais fait c'est à
dire le problème est qu normes toutes
sont forts ces temps forts et tu
négocies plus quoi et en fait larmes
gelé enterré dans le désert
je m'en suis séparé en préférant
maintenant la négociation mais j'ai eu
peur j'ai eu peur de moi
toi là où je me sens vraiment tranquille
vraiment tranquille et en paix quand je
marche des jours et des jours que je
vois pas une trace de voiture n 3 à 4 4
pas une trace de troupeaux et du sable
que du sable et là je me sens vraiment
sécurité quoi depuis le départ régis
s'efforce de progresser d'environ 35 km
par jour en fonction du terrain parfois
il en fait plus de 50
c'était une jour nous en avait bavé mais
bavay et je m'arrête je m'approche près
d'un buisson est sûre ce buisson il y
avait des des centaines de papillons et
c'était tellement beau à voir
ces papillons qui sont envolés à mon
approche que je me suis dit bio c'était
un petit côté paradis et je me suis dit
bah finalement dans la ville est
possible encore ici c'était indique cet
arbre avec leurs emplettes papillon et
du coup bah ça m'a fait passer là ça m'a
fait passer la rancoeur de la journée et
j'ai trouvé lui votre magnifique
85e jours de marche environ 3500 km en
ligne droite
malheureusement donc il me reste
facilement facilement le double et je
vais vous présenter ma dernière
acquisition lazareff dumont nouveau chat
moore 11e chamois un grand chameau
touareg azarov c'était le plus beau chat
mots que j'ai eus je dis pas ça pour te
faire plaisir c'est vrai mais qu'est ce
que tu comptes j'aime bien qu'on tient
le silence
je crois que je vais seulement
déterminées et les chameaux je te pose
la caméra sur la tête
la langue de bois
depuis depuis cinq jours alors c'est de
l'ocré été tirée d'un puits d'un puits
dont les parois étaient en branchages se
perd pas attraper d'amibes mais des fois
y'a pas le choix de l'os et glou
[Musique]
régis parvient à la frontière entre le
mali et le niger il cherche un passage
dont ces roches et les chameaux sont
inquiets comme toujours lorsqu'il ne
voit plus l'horizon
[Musique]
ce matin régis a enfin franchi la
frontière elle est délimité par cette
barrière rocheuse surplombant loued de
l'azaouagh après un passage
particulièrement difficile ils arrivent
sur le territoire nigérien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est mon centième jour de
marche la mère dans lequel j'évolue
c'était morceaux de schiste relativement
anciens détachées il ya fort longtemps
des montagnes environnantes qui ont été
amenées par lowe's époque humide et
éclatée par la suite au soleil donc ça
fait déjà très tranchantes
c'est des cailloux de merde qui me pompe
l'air qui découpent les pieds de méchas
mots et [__] et on n'avance pas j'ai
mon show mots qui s'est blessé alors je
lui ai fait un chausson avec la peau de
ficelle et un morceau de nos chambres à
air en fait c'est là des looks la des
loups c'était la réception qui me
servait puiser l'eau dans les puits mais
il est complètement ville à la seule qui
est complètement usés il a les pieds qui
tient son seul réconfort de la journée
c'est qu'il semble y avoir un petit peu
d'herbe là bas donc je pense que je vais
poser bivouac
[__] j'ai rarement connu des journées
de galère comme ça n'avance pas qu'est
ce que je fous dans ce merdier
moi ce que je redoute c'est une ivresse
dû à la fatigue dû à la déshydratation
et perdre la notion du danger ça c'est
important il faut que je continue
d'avoir peur il faut absolument le jeu
géant dans un coin de ma tête
cette notion de peur
continuer d'avoir peur ça veut dire que
l'esprit et le corps reste en alerte
régis est sur un fil il ne faut pas
qu'il bascule
[Musique]
ça c'est des moments de grand bonheur
voyage quand on tombe sur des gravures
on cherche sans arrêt la journée mais là
j'en attendais un salto bivouac juste à
côté de deux gravures rupestres comme ça
de cette ampleur c'est maintenant tu
sais pourquoi tu es là c'est vous
traversez la ire est arrivé à la porte
du ténéré ça représente la moitié du
parcours j'ai fait pas loin d'eux
de quatre mille bornes au lieu d'en
faire de 1800 les mois sont passés les
jours se sont écoulés
les chaleurs vont revenir là l'année
toutes les caravanes sont arrêtés dans
le ténéré
plus personne ne traverse le ténéré pour
aller chercher le sel habilement il va
faire trop chaud maintenant bloqué à
table lot le dernier village avant le
grand aîné ray il sera provisionnent ça
je vais je prendre 250g de prendre
quatre mesures attendues me donne pas la
balle est maintenant ça fait 3500 pour
le riz 3500 250000 ça fait 4500
salamalecs always je t'en prendre 4 554
ça c est né sait combien s'enflammer
[Musique]
régis doit emporter 130 litres d'eau et
de la paille pour les chameaux il en a
actuellement deux le premier à 1200 km
dans les pattes et il n'est pas sûr de
lui il faut qu'il en trouve un troisième
attentat gervans mal évidemment comme je
suis blanc et que souvent j'ai pas le
temps
ce que j'essaye de faire au maximum
c'est d'échanger
[Musique]
non ça j'en veux pas j'en veux pas il et
j'ai pas le temps de le dresser celui là
il est trop trop nerveux
c'est un bon chapeau mais j'ai pas le
temps la difficulté que rencontrent
c'est qu'il ya plus plus assez de
chameaux dans la hutte et j'ai beaucoup
de mal à en trouver pour le tombe à
traverser j'ai traversé des zones où les
gens avaient tout perdu
vraiment tout permis et tous les
chameaux thérèse son parti sont partis
au sud pour avoir des meilleurs
pâturages 238 je pense que je vais
prendre celui là est en cuir juste pour
leur part d'un point c'est à dire est-ce
que s'il ya des éleveurs qui est du
détail près des lots en creusant 30 km
d'accord donc ils prennent un loup garou
à new delhi m dos ouais mais cette année
et l'an dernier il n'a pas pu cette
année il ya vraiment réussi des circuits
à tête où elle dans la région s'est
offert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec ces oasis ses jardins et ses oued
le massif de l'aïr passer pour un éden
dans le sahara mais depuis quelques
décennies la sécheresse empire le bétail
meurt et les populations sahariennes
sont trop souvent contraintes à une
migration vers les villes
[Musique]
le chameau qui l'a trouvée hattab lot et
le plus résistant de tout ce qu'il a vu
dans la région mais il n'a pas encore
l'expérience du voyage caravaniers
comment réagira-t-il en voyant les
étendues infinies de sable qui les
attendent dans le ténéré
habitué aux pâturages des zones
rocheuses de l'aïr il devra se contenter
désormais d'une maigre ration de paille
desséché
c'est un prêt sans ça c'est très très
difficile à traverser j'aurais pas dû
monter parce que l'ajout à ce qui
m'attend dans les jours à venir et là où
ça me fait peur quand je vois cette
masse de cailloux là
avec aucune tache verte à l'horizon
j'ai fait peut-être une découverte
intéressante peut-être un morceaux de
météorite il ya deux choses qui
pourraient me faire penser une météorite
c'est qu'on dirait qu'une espèce de
croûtes de fusion comme si ça avait été
travaillé par l'homme alors que ça ne
l'est pas il ya surtout une
cristallisation anarchique dessus qui
correspond pas une cristallisation
filoniennes comment on peut trouver ici
donc je sais pas je vais ramener ce
morceau au muséum et puis et puis le
faire analyser
[Musique]
donc là c'est le dernier pluie avant
avant 150 km dans le sahara on ne refuse
jamais de donner de l'eau à un homme
c'est la solidarité
mais parfois quand le niveau des prix
est trop bas on peut refuser d'abreuver
les animaux sont souvent offert de l'eau
on m'a rempli mes petits bidons
puisqu'ils pouvaient toi et puis en
échange et donner du sucre et du thé
c'est un échange quoi c'est le commerce
à rien c'est normal trentaine de mètres
comme halluin 105 m hélas et des puits
où il faut impérativement le matériel
causé à la longueur de corde le chameau
pour tirer parce que l'on s'amuse pas à
remonter des outres de 20 litres quoi
céder ou de 54
[Musique]
au puy dakar aib quelques familles
touareg mène une vie pastorale elle
l'aide à remplir ses réserves d'eau
avant l'éprouvant de traverse et qu'il
attend
[Musique]
régis gardera en mémoire ces sourires et
ses visages les derniers qu'il verra
avant plusieurs semaines
parfois régis monde sur le dos dasa rêve
pour quelques heures en fin de journée
lorsqu'il se sent trop fatigué mais il
doit le ménager pour éviter de l'épuiser
inutilement
hé hé
chaque chose a toujours une double
utilité
tout est exploité au maximum celle des
crottes pour faire le faire des crottes
pour faire les courses apprendre à
exploiter au maximum l environnement est
très très peu
mon
moore
[Musique]
au bout
régis profit du bivouac pour préparer la
provision qu'il donnera au chameau quand
dans le ténéré
ils ne trouveront plus rien à manger par
eux mêmes au repos un chameau peut
passer trois à quatre mois sans boire
mais avec les efforts quotidiens qu'ils
fournissent il se déshydrate rapidement
l'important c'est de partir avant le
lever du soleil pour abattre au plus tôt
les premiers kilomètres de la journée
avant l'étouffante chaleur
[Musique]
proverbe toi et on tient plus de force
il reste encore le courage pour
combattre
[Musique]
on
bien des fois j'ai réfléchi et je me dis
qu'il faut tout fixe un but plus près
pour t'arrêter parce que si tu t'arrêtes
pas tu m'as y rester je me dis allez et
ses navires au tchad
on
partir d'un océan que tu laisses dans
ton dos est d'arriver à un océan que tu
vas prendre en pleine face
enfin une autre mère que tu prends plein
france
[Musique]
c'est ça qui est beau c'est qu'il n'y a
rien du tout
[Musique]
dans ma tête la belle vie d'avant
j'attends j'écoute les herbes et quand
j'entends les agiter un courant d'air
qui va arriver
les jeunes à tort
on arrive au mois de mars et la chaleur
commence il ya un vent qui s'appelle
l'harmattan qui va commencer à souffler
maintenant que j'ai de l'ombre de l'eau
et de la nourriture
continuez d'avancer mais c'est lui qui
vont être en restriction totale
c'est le pire en altérer c'est un no
man's land total c'est un territoire
qu'il faut traverser ou plus vite
c'est un territoire de mort contre les
zones huppées arrive du sahara
préparant j'ai rencontré des chefs de
tribus qui m'ont garantit une sécurité
en traversant leur territoire dans le
ténéré ya personne n'y a pas de loi dans
le derrière aucune loi c'est la loi du
plus fort il ya une immigration
clandestine qui remonte sur la libye
avec des camions qui tombe en panne
j'imagine j'imagine si je tombe sur sur
30 bus qui sont à court d'eau qui sont à
court de nourriture qui sont en panne au
milieu du désert et si je tombe dessus
jeu dépouillé quoi dépouillés
je suis arrivé comme un âne dans le
ténéré en sortant des rouges avait un
pas dans les cailloux assez rythmé pour
abattre des kilomètres
et là en fait la transition s'est fait
en deux heures en deux heures les
montées sont complètement effacés il
fait rêver dans la plaine du teigneux
à la même vitesse
le sable domine
régis s'épuise
la première partie de la traversée du
ténéré se fait en suivant des panneaux
kilométrique qui balisent la piste
précieux repères pour le voyageur
solitaire
pour l'esprit c'est très déstabilisant
ne pas avoir de repères visuels et donc
les repères il voulait chercher il faut
les chercher à l'intérieur de soi dans
l'ombre de tes pas dans mon côté chabot
en train de vie mettre un mélange de
natron tabac sa descente dans sa gorge
par le nez il va lui donner un peu de
pêche le problème c'est que le chameau
et les malades c'est à dire qu'il a le
sang qui s'est là c'est un peu épaissie
et ils risquent malgré de mourir kouassi
continue à faire des efforts comme ça
c'est comme un chameau cabine 1300 km
dans l'est dans les pattes et et j'en ai
besoin et je suis pas sûr qu'ils
puissent traverser le ténéré
c'est un peu celui qui motive aussi tous
les matins quoi quand je vois sa bonne
tête sa stature sa force
ça me donne du courage
si régis l'abandonnent ici loin de tout
pâturages c'est la mort assurée
il faut garder à l'esprit que c'est pas
toi qui traversent le désert c'était
chamakh qui traverse que les besoins
sont plus importants que toi il faut
toujours avoir à l'esprit si tu veux
pouvoir compter sur eux et puis avancer
quoi
là ça me rappelle des souvenirs cette
platitude ça me rappelle le marier à la
frontière malienne et mauritanienne et
donc ses souvenirs mexique parce que
c'était extrêmement difficile mais en
même temps à la peur quoi parce que là
je vais tout droit sur la cuy je sais
pas si ado c'est un plus qui s'en
servent très vite et si les pas
entretenues n'y a pas d'eau et le
prochain puis les deux centièmes loin
là ce qui domine dans mes pensées c'est
atteindre un point de faire demi-tour
maintenant c'est trop tard aussi loin
d'un côté que de l'autre nous voyons
régis arrive au puits de l'arbre du
ténéré par chance il n'est pas en sable
et mais il faut puiser l'eau à 40 mètres
de profondeur rien ils sont en train
d'attaquer méchamment non il faut
dégager d'ici mais ça sort d'où cette
invasion
sandrine par l'éthique c'est fou jamais
vu ça
elles veulent pas se coucher parce qu'il
ya trop petit qui est maire depuis
[Musique]
plus de 30 fois il a dû remonter loutre
de 20 litres pour étancher la soif des
chameaux et la sienne
[Musique]
mais
oh
en quittant ce puits
régis sait qu'il lui faudra parcourir au
moins 180 kilomètres avant de trouver le
prochain avec les 90 litres d'eau qui
l'embarquent il a de quoi tenir deux
semaines
il veut finir la traversée du ténéré en
plus vite
il donnera à boire aux chameaux en deux
fois pour qu'il prenne une quantité
maximum d'eau avant le départ
[Musique]
plus le temps passe moi je j'ai envie de
prendre de risque et ça c'est pas parce
que je masse agit c'est parce que
c'est parce que je suis épuisée et puis
je sais que je serai pas capable du même
type d'effort que ce que j'aurais pu
faire il ya deux mois en arrière
si jamais il ya un problème
[Musique]
au contact des nomades régis a appris
une chose quand on a un problème dans le
désert on s'arrête on fait un thé et
après on réfléchit
[Musique]
l'équipe de tournage kit régissent le
rendant à sa solitude
[Musique]
il fait chaud fille 44° attendre sur
cette ouverture non plus que j'ai fait
20 km avant la grosse chaleur
prochain point d'eau il est 170 km
flashy
[Musique]
126e jours de marche
la tempête se lève régis ne voit plus
aucun relief au delà de 100 m ils
rebroussent chemin face à des murs de
sable s'épuise et ses réserves d'eau
diminue il décide de s'arrêter en
attendant que le vent se calme pour se
protéger de la déshydratation il
s'enterre dans le sable la tempête ne
faiblit pas depuis deux jours
c'est produire un jeu dans le tenait
j'ai déclenché les secours ce matin
c'est pas ta vie très dure et ils vont
arriver d'ici 24 heures jésus vérité
toute la paille aux chamois
[Musique]
si je mange et j'ai peur d'y rester pour
épuisement
je trouve donc en rien
derrière c'était dur c'est tellement
et vous
l'équipe se trouvait encore à agadez
elle organise les secours et lui il
faudra 24 heures pour rejoindre régis
[Musique]
une piste périlleuse et au milieu de la
nuit une lampe qui clignotent
[Musique]
là
oh
cette tempête de sable a privé régis de
toute visibilité au moment de franchir
un cordon dunaire ils se trouvaient
encore à une centaine de kilomètres du
prochain puis cherche en vain des
passages pour ses chameaux il s'est
épuisé
cet effort supplémentaire a aggravé sa
déshydratation incapacité à se tenir
debout fièvre vomissements confusion
mentale en ont été les symptômes
[Musique]
les conditions climatiques
exceptionnellement chaudes et son
affaiblissement physiologique ont eu
raison de sa détermination
pour autant cette expérience ne l'a pas
découragé il affrontera à nouveau ses
milieu saharien en solitaire il s'y
prépare déjà
mon
[Musique]
pour
oh
[Musique]
voilà
non
[Musique]